hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay we just
killed our a mini boss of some sorts and
I'm going to get rid of the force gun
cuz it seems like a pile of crap and I
don't need that many of those over here
and I'm going to pick out another again
uh seeker rifle dealt a seeker rifle I
don't know okay
let's give it a try why not alright
let's do it okay
I remember the lady Danny telling me to
go find a tram station of some sort of
lips up no go yeah entering vacuum thank
you lady computer
who's this computer lady anyway fine so
patient care uh-huh
okay anyway let me see if there was any
goodies over here give up goodie because
obviously goodies are gonna be a little
bit rare when it comes to zealot mode
and I know some of you are concerned
that maybe um maybe that because for
some reason I got DLC without knowing
and I got some extra goodies I don't
think it's gonna be a bit that big of an
advantage because I did some research
and this shoot this suit I have isn't
the best suit in the game it's just kind
of good best soon the game has about 30%
armor this only has I think 15 who wants
some
Paul anybody dark reminds me of the
issue Mara we on a space station or a
ship or something where the heck are we
anyway I don't even know quote Grif
enabled up Aussie funk oh no oh no oh no
I don't like I don't like it all but I'm
okay I'm brave bring it on
we got armor now
okay we're good who wants some hmm
another store Oh wha huh don't touch
hello Manu lo5 Sorensen okay okay that
makes sense
calms you down and cut after them that's
pretty much the staple for everything
I've seen so far so why not all right
let's see you about upgrading I know I
got some power notes I remember I need
to keep some Wow I got five already
haven't even bought any right the one
gun that I know I'm gonna keep with me
is the plasma cutter because obviously
via blah blah blah
hey damn it Cass - okay see Riggs still
cry as AI air and health what's that
he's a damage of TK impalement Oh
telekinesis oh oh that's handy and if I
remember those when I decayed I guess
it's what they call it decayed total
knockout take a dumb the the little bars
into the enemies that killed him
instantly so that's trial
good stasis that looks about the same Oh
charge I fasted Auto charges whoo I'll
grate that eventually um as far as these
other weapons I don't know which I'm
gonna I'm gonna keep I'm gonna keep
rotating them out until I find one that
I really like
now some health ought to do okay Ken Cal
keep two with me boy fect all right let
me try this secret right next I don't
have anything I need to sell in the
store oh hello
chips wait ships are we on a planet
oh it's like a city Oh nope today madam
apologize for being nope ah I knew it
get up yeah I don't know what that did
exactly but it killed you
so I got four shots that's not very
funny
now my way to share vitamins oh you are
one ugly MF o man when everyone was ugly
something to me right
woo iron owed star-nosed lakhs
yes first one do a good idea yeah yeah
oh yeah text log we got Titan station
economic report Titan station
unemployment grew unexpectedly by nine
point five percent due to collateral job
losses from the ongoing collapse of
local planet cracking business the
aftermath of the emphysema incident
continues to press all planned cracking
activity as more and more support device
services go out of business leaving less
and less capacity for planet cracking
however Titan station continues to post
a purse mall profit buoyed solely by the
cash influx from EarthGov scientific
research and operations facility human
needs and services organization has been
spared the brunt of the planet cracking
collapse by the pickup and traffic with
government sector planet cracking docks
ship services mining supplies and tool
vendors continue to post heavy losses
however the CC itself has found modern
new life for its facility in the Rd
Department of the government okay so
they know about being shimmery they know
that dastardly deeds went down there who
did it can be a power node
aw didn't okay I had to I thought I saw
power node is it like a power node
schematic huh it was let me go dump that
off of me uh how did I miss these box I
need them I need a dust off because I
don't have a lot of inventory space
that's another reason that this this
suit isn't the best it doesn't have the
max inventory because it's only got 15
watts as opposed to 25 equalizer so I'm
pretty sure this is still gonna be a
good Challenger all right what else well
where all these come from well hell it's
just throwing so much crap at me in the
store oh these are ammo
okay I'll pulse rounds my old friend but
not them oh um oh it wouldn't give me
the line gun in the javelin gun right
away it's not bad see if your shells oh
the secret rifle okay that's the one I'm
using right now okay that's not that's
not bad at all and the only engineering
suit I would have was 10 and 15
heavy-duty vintage suit
anyway either way I'm in good shape but
I don't have a considerable revenge
because I mean it gave me the guns but
the guns are useless without ammo and my
attention okay I know there are more
safe [ __ ] old habits die hard
they went out there oh oh hi person are
you gonna die yep hey you get off of her
want some welcome you're done yeah Oh
heads lotion and now I'm out of ammo
see it's good but not that good
oh hello people run away ah bat batty
boo redline I can't oh I'm out of ammo
and that one
oh no there we go that looks familiar
how did these monsters get here did they
did I bring him with me wait why did
they ignore that guy did a perfect did I
bring him with me when I came power no
they brought me back to where we are
wait that doesn't make sense I would
posit himself bring back the infection
if he wasn't in fact whoa what the hell
it's his head
ah don't scream at me bro I can't zoom
it in like an Indonesian Oh pop I got
head oh my gun line gun there we go haha
legs
hahaha okay anyway lots of screaming
it's nice to hear other human voices
that aren't in my head but I'd rather
they tan line
elevator I love me some elevator it's
been too long since I've been riding
what was that okay Oh want some
something laughs hey aren't you helping
Isaac
did you help him more people died in in
front of Isaac Isaac come on good whoa
hi sorry buddy
what Isaac over here oh hey oh they gave
us trucks today forget the guesswork
why are you calling me I think why you
calling me what ah oh hello
I remember you ah I'm out of mana Emmet
Emmet whicker's by gun ah okay those bad
there we go friggin get to the right gun
oh hey this suit looks really badass by
the way I just want to say that rash
take a look at this look at that
handsome mother rigger
right bidding that video inside that
room these are like residential areas
that would seem really weird to be able
to see into the room at all times
Oh
Hey okay so basically the gist of it is
it dying everywhere and I know when he
guys said that it was quite dark it's
quite dark for me too hey survivors
where what the hell no no not today
hey I could have I could have made some
friends you what were you running away
from damn it I wanted some friends I
need a hug she say you're not leaving
your mother Phoebe ah that's her mother
jeez she's really lovely she is oh just
been a bit too much time sunbathing
skin's a little
huh we're good
toilet Oh got ya he'll owe you a dime
whoops I wasted some ammo which is like
a cardinal sin in disguise don't you get
out of your room if you're just being
murdered to death
trashcan hmm Oh
the hell
does it sound like there's a little kid
in there
okay okay
getting all
oh good huh
ah I miss there you go
your goodies give me that good you give
me your goodies there we go ah no not
today
ah ah what the hell I'm eating the man
what the hell was that oh yeah I can't
even tell us I think he's ripping his
talib it's so frickin dark in here ah
not today
there we go all tasted not last long
anymore huh oh man is really so dark ah
no no no not tonight all right
I took forever oh I ran out of ammo oh
no I think I just ran out of ammo I've
never run out of ammo before I had like
thirty shot okay time for the grenade
launcher
okay did I miss anything from the bodies
there's something at least a teddy bear
I'm taking you with me teddy come on
come on we're gonna go somewhere safe
how much help
well I'm s to pick up the teddy but I
guess this is just good okay that's
actually all the time I got for this
episode thank you guys so much for
watching and as always see you in the
next part
bye bye